she's started like a website and a tick  tock account about  like living proud with herpes  you shouldn't live proud with herpes you  can live with herpes there's no shame in  it right but there is a little shame in  it there's a little shame in herpes like  people have stds a lot of people have  represented it's not like a  gots to go situation but if you're  telling everyone about your herpes  that's a gots to go situation  right you you don't need to  like hide it from your loved ones of  course uh some of them like my sisters  don't need to know about my herpes  i i guess i was thinking more of like  someone you're sleeping with you should  definitely let them know  yeah she says her husband  really supported her encouraged her uh  to become  a herpes influencer i think if you get  herpes you don't know what to do you  know who to talk to and you find someone  on tick-tock whose whole thing is that  they have herpes and they're happy with  it then i think that would be helpful